in history driving a robust recovery
from the economic catastrophe he
inherited the number of new jobless
claims americans filing for unemployment
for the first time fell below the
pre-pandemic average in 2019 and the
number of americans who have been
receiving unemployment benefits for more
than a week fell to the lowest level
since 1970. three hundred thousand fewer
americans are receiving unemployment
claims now than before the pandemic that
means more americans are getting back to
work and fewer are drawing governmental
government benefits as we've said many
times the data can be volatile week to
week or month to month so it's important
to focus on the broader trends and those
trends show remarkable progress across
our economy over the last year including
the fastest year of job growth in u.s
history with 7.4 million jobs created
and unemployment down to 3.8 percent i
also wanted to mark another historic
milestone of 500 million vaccines that
we have distributed to the world an
unprecedented campaign reaching 113
countries something that has never been
done before we did not get here by
accident this is a testament to the same
whole of government effort we applied
domestically navigating logistical legal
and regulatory processes to get
life-saving vaccines across the world as
we mark today's milestone of delivering
a half a billion vaccines to the world
let me be clear without additional
funding from congress to support getting
shots into arms usaid will have to cut
short our crucial and effective efforts
to turn vaccines into vaccinations
congress must promptly provide the
administration with the urgent funding
we need to continue the work of both
vaccinating the world and protecting
americans at home
last thing i just wanted to note um as
you saw this morning reported uh jeff
science uh who has served as our covid
coordinator will soon uh be leaving so i
just wanted to take a moment just to
note his service and thank him from the
president and all of us the president
called on jeff to lead our cobit 19
response because there is no one better
at delivering results i know this
personally i worked closely with him
through many challenges over the course
of many years in public service in
government and the thing about jeff is
at every moment at every opportunity
when there is a big challenge a pile of
manure sometimes he dives right in to
fix the challenge and that's what he
does that is what he has done time and
time again through his career in public
service and he led this effort to stand
up a mass vaccination campaign achieve
equity and vaccinations across
communities ensure that americans have
access to treatments tests and embark on
an unprecedented global vaccine campaign
that we celebrate can celebrate today it
would not have happened without jeff
zions in this job and in this role
and we are stronger that he is his
service and the service of his deputy
natalie quillian who's also departing uh
has literally saved lives in this
country so we want to thank them uh for
their work um for their leadership and
we will miss them a great deal here jake
why don't you kick us off thanks ken um
first on covet uh the president has had
a couple of close calls of the last
couple days and gentlemen and the
average prime minister
last night has he been tested today
he was not tested today was tested last
sunday
neither of these individuals were
considered closed contacts the doctors
at the cdc determine what closed
contacts look like and that a close
contact is someone who is less than six
feet away from an infected infected
person for a cumulative total of 15
minutes or more over a 24 hour period
that is how they define it and of course
our doctors look closely at that as well
and neither of these two individuals uh
what did he spend that amount of time
with um and so his weekly testing
cadence remains as it has been it has
not changed
yeah there are a number of particular
precautions that exist you know to
protect the president and keep him safe
and healthy uh the testing uh cadence
here is not like the most feeling yeah
that's right
this is this broader issue though of the
president coming into maybe not cbc
close contact but having close exposure
to some people even for a brief amount
of time
you know you know getting into that
bubble around the president but this is
something that people around the country
are dealing with on a daily basis but
they don't have the same sort of
precautions
so you know if the president
hypothetically were to come down with
coke's event something or or any or the
first lady or anyone else in this
administration is that a failure at this
point or is this just a new fact of life
that everyone has to sort of you know
make it you know
well it was very soothing i don't know
where that came from um
i would say our view is while we've made
a significant amount of progress um
across the country in fighting the
pandemic with more than 75 percent of
adults uh fully vaccinated according to
the definition of the cdc and obviously
we've seen hospitalizations come down
across the country including washington
dc uh the president was very clear when
he made his remarks about covid just a
few weeks ago that uh we are still
working we still have work to do to
address the pandemic to fight the
pandemic that's exactly why we need
additional funding to make sure we have
the types of treatments the types of
testing mechanisms to make them free and
available to americans across the
country to make masks available so that
people who are uninsured or people who
don't have the resources can tap into a
lot of these
these effective treatments and effective
prevention mechanisms
i would say for us you're right the
testing
the testing modes are a little bit
different around here um because we are
around the president of the united
states and the vice president and of
course the first lady and the second
gentleman
that means before you see the president
um you are in it for a meeting or you
travel with him
you are tested and everyone has
different uh testing cadences depending
on their frequency of seeing him and
then uh
president and professor g tomorrow
has this government made a determination
whether china has decided whether or not
to
uh
sort of agree to russia's request to
provide existence sports uh
invading the ukraine um is that is it
still a live ball that the president is
going to warn president g off of what
where
are they in terms of making that
decision sure well why don't i give you
a little bit more of a preview on the
call and hopefully we'll answer exactly
your question um the president as i
think you've heard him say before and
i've said is a big believer and leader
to leader diplomacy
and they have a lot to discuss given the
last time the president met with
president xi virtually was last november
a couple of months ago the meeting
tomorrow in terms of how we got here
came as a direct follow-up to the
meeting our national security adviser
jake sullivan had with his counterpart
they talked about the two presidents uh
meeting or engaging in the near future
during that meeting so hence it is
happening tomorrow and that meeting
earlier this week of course came at an
important moment in the conflict but it
also in ukraine of course it also
covered issues beyond russia's invasion
and i would expect of ukraine i would
expect this meeting would as well
because there are obviously a range of
issues that we continue to discuss with
the chinese and the president discusses
of course when he speaks with president
xi but to go to your question um this is
an opportunity for president biden to
assess uh where president xi stands uh
there's been of course rhetorical
support or the absence of clear rhetoric
and denunciation or the absence of
denunciation by china of what russia is
doing
this flies in the face of course of
everything china stands for including uh
the basic principles of the u.n charter
including the basic principles of
respect for sovereignty of nations and
so the fact that china has not denounced
what russia is doing in and of itself
speaks volumes and it also speaks
volumes not only in russia and ukraine
but around the world and this call also
comes as the as jake sullivan's meeting
earlier this week as we have made clear
our deep concerns about china's
alignment with russia and the potential
implications and consequences of that so
the president will also share his
assessment of that during the call but i
don't have another an update for you on
any internal assessment that is just how
we are approaching or he is approaching
the call tomorrow
how specific is the president going to
be in laying out the consequences for
china if they do help russia well the
president is uh never fails to be direct
including in his conversations with
president xi um but
we'll let the call happen and i'm sure
we'll have more to read out for you
after the call the idea what military
equipment they are thinking about
providing russia
i don't have any assessment of that from
here and what do you make of the putin
comments basically calling for a purge
of anti-war opponents
well i think this is uh
a clear sign that this war is not going
uh how president putin planned for it to
go uh and there has been an outpouring
of uh courageous uh protests uh and uh
and many speaking out against the war
even within russia so his effort to
crack down on dissent to crack down on
the freedom of press on the freedom of
media and the freedom of protest is
actually quite consistent with what
we've seen his approach to be over the
course of the last several years but i
think it's an indication of exactly that
go ahead which side requested this call
between president biden and president xi
tomorrow it was discussed on the during
the call during the meeting that uh that
our national security advisor had on
monday are you thinking it was mutually
agreed upon they mutually agreed to move
forward with it uh during that meeting
secretary of lincoln just said that the
us is concerned china is considering
directly assisting russia by providing
them with more military equipment to use
in ukraine that is not something that we
have heard from the administration
before and so can i guess you speak to
how high of a concern that is from the
for the white house right now
it is a high concern significant concern
given our secretary of state
just conveyed that and certainly our
concerns about china assisting in any
way russia as they invade a foreign
country is of significant concern and
would uh the response to that would be
uh consequences before russia invaded
the white house is pretty clear that if
they did invade there would be sanctions
imposed on them as a result of that with
china you've just said if they do help
russia that there will be consequences
but you haven't said specifically that
they will be sanctions can you say
without saying what they are that they
will be sanctioned if they do help
russia with military equipment for this
invasion i'm just not going to outline
what the consequences would look like
and i uh i uh the president obviously
will speak with president xi tomorrow
and he'll speak directly about about
that
go ahead just on that point just unclear
i mean i understand you don't want to
detail what the consequences could be
but the president in the phone call will
make clear not just that there will be
consequences but what those consequences
could be i'm sure we'll have more to
read out after the call happens tomorrow
but uh we have not uh our national
security advisor obviously didn't hold
back in his conversation he had our
secretary of state did not hold back in
his comments he just made publicly and
uh the president always takes the
opportunity when he speaks with foreign
leaders to be candid and direct
the phone calls can be an opportunity to
assess where she stands um should we
take that to mean that it's not clear
that the chinese have made up their mind
whether or not to assist the russians
well i think if you look at the last
couple of weeks mary you can see that
they abstained from a vote in the u.n
security council but they also and they
they hadn't put out a comment during the
munich security conference defending the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine but they also echoed
some of the conspiracy theories about
chemical weapons and u.s and ukrainian
intentions so for any country it's a
question of where you want to be as the
history books are written
and could you believe that this is a
sign that that or can you
characterize at all your understanding
of how low the russians may be running
on some military equipment given that
they seem to be turning to china for
some help i can't provide an assessment
in that uh from here uh but you know i
know my colleagues at the department of
defense have conveyed clearly and i'm
happy to echo that it's not only not
going as they planned um they have had
challenges obviously with the operations
of equipment with the amount of
equipment uh even with mres and food and
other supplies um and you know that that
is what we have seen uh occur on the
ground but i don't have a a
numerical uh summary from here go ahead
thank you jen so one of the clearest
responses you have seen from the chinese
about their possibly helping russia came
from the foreign minister wang yi
who told spanish officials on a call
china is not a party to the crisis
nor does it want the sanctions to affect
china what sanctions are they talking
about
did
jake sullivan specifically bring up
sanctions during the meeting in rome i i
can't speak to what he meant you'd have
to ask the chinese okay well has has the
chinese expressed the same thing to the
us that they do not want to run the risk
of being sanctioned i would the chinese
would speak for themselves we typically
don't speak uh for others okay so um
just now and uh secretary of lincoln
joined ambassador greenfield and the
president
and describing clinton's actions as war
crimes i know that you said just
yesterday that there's a legal process
that is ongoing
how long does that process typically
take how much evidence do we need to
collect and
can you clarify who will ultimately
determine
whether these are war crimes or not well
i think secretary blinken in his remarks
also gave some specifics about who from
the state department will be leading
that effort it's a legal process where
they review all of the evidence and then
they provide that evidence and data and
information to the international bodies
that oversee the investigations and the
international bodies that oversee the
investigations
would make determinations about a
violation of international law and
whether it's war crimes by their
standards and what the consequences
would be so we would be supporting those
efforts do you know how long that
usually takes a legal process internally
in the state department it can take some
time but again i can't i would point to
the state department for any update they
want to provide on the timeline one more
on jeff science um he and dr shaw who's
going to replace him have such
very different backgrounds and different
skill sets
so what does that say about how the
stage of the pandemic has evolved from
then and now sure well i would say what
it says is that jeff zion's superpower
is that he is an operational and
managerial guru of sorts um and someone
who uh has taken those skills to a range
of jobs he's had
throughout his career including in the
obama biden administration when he
oversaw the fixing of healthcare.gov and
oversaw the fixing of the technology
that was severely broken and outdated
within government at that time
so when we came into this administration
i would remind you it's now a long time
ago uh there was no real plan we were
left no plan by our predecessors we
needed to put in place to plan to not
only get enough access to vaccines but
also ensure there are enough vaccinators
and vaccine locations that's a massive
operational undertaking right now we're
at a point in the process where we have
all of the tools and we know the
operational systems that are needed and
so right now it's the the uh appropriate
time and jeff of course made this
decision uh uh on his own he extended a
couple of times uh to stay longer
through some ups and downs in the
pandemic we're having a public health
expert somebody who's as no as well
known uh as dr shaw is it is
effective in communicating with the
country about how we're going to
continue to approach and tackle the
pandemic
go ahead thanks jen um the president
called putin a war criminal yesterday
the
secretary of state just said that that
was also his view today
given all of that why are we still
having putin's russia broker the iran
nuclear deal
well i would say that it's not in our
interest for iran to acquire a nuclear
weapon and russia is a member of the p5
plus one so uh that is pursuit of a deal
that would be in our national security
with him interests again i think how the
president and any of the p5 plus one
partners or europeans or others uh look
at this is if we can
achieve a diplomatic solution where we
prevent iran from acquiring a nuclear
weapon despite the uh efforts by uh by
former president trump to pull us out of
the deal allowing iran to move far move
closer to acquiring nuclear weapon that
would be good for our national security
and good for global security around the
world
iran nuclear
agreement review act says that congress
is required to review any new agreement
this is obviously not the same agreement
that
obama worked on in 2015.
does president biden believe that this
treaty
needs the advice and consent of congress
and if so does he believe he has the
votes to
lawfully affirm it
well if if and when we have a deal and
we don't have a deal at this point
otherwise you would all know um we would
carefully consider the facts and
circumstances of any u.s return to the
jcpoa to determine the legal
implications including those under the
iran nuclear review act of 2015 and
we're committed to ensuring the
requirements are satisfied so certainly
we would abide by that but we have been
keeping uh members very updated we've
been briefing them regularly uh brett
mcgurk conducted a call just a couple
days ago and we've been briefing them
with a range of national security
officials and then has the igrc
or done any or rather the islamic
revolutionary guard corps the irgc
has it done anything to be eligible to
be removed from the terror blacklist
well i think you're asking me this
because it's been out there as a
possible discussion but there's no deal
at this point so if and when there's a
deal we'll have a discussion about
what's in the deal outside of the deal
does it take
action to be removed from that terror
blacklist do you have to do something to
get off of it you have to make a
decision yes go ahead thanks jen i want
to ask you a slightly different version
of a question that i asked you yesterday
about the 800 million military
assistance um i asked if you could tell
us how quickly it would arrive and i
understand this complicated process to
flip it around a little bit can you tell
us how quickly will the first shipment
be out the door
well we've been doing shipments or
deliveries every day or every couple of
days and obviously the department of
defense would have more specifics but we
have effectively and successfully
delivered 300 million dollars in
military assistance to the ukrainians on
the ground over just the last two weeks
and our effort would be to continue to
rapidly provide and provide equipment
this new trunk this new 800
million dollar announcement can you give
us just characterize how quickly
this round will start to be central the
operations of that would be led uh by
the department of defense so i'd point
to them for more operational specifics
and to stay on the department of defense
the defense secretary was speaking with
his slovakian counterpart who said that
they were willing to send long-range
s-300 surface-to-air missiles if the u.s
would backfill
um does the administration see this as a
done deal with something that is
imminent
well it's the decision of any foreign
country as a sovereign country to decide
what equipment they want to provide what
we are mindful of is ensuring that we
are maintaining uh we have to be careful
in our desire to support other countries
that we're not inadvertently impacting
nato readiness or capabilities or our
own
and again this is something the
department of defense can most
effectively speak to but a lot of these
military systems
would some of them require months
to manufacture to build we just don't we
don't have a
warehouse of just
military
equipment that's ready to typically be
sent all the time so uh that is a factor
but uh we want to find a solution that
both enables allies and partners to
provide the support they have available
to ukraine while addressing the very
real need to backfill the defense
systems which is often a significant
challenge and we just want to make sure
that if and when our allies are donating
material including us they're not
leaving a gap in their own defenses okay
and
just finally um
ukrainian refugees are being turned away
at the southern border and we've gotten
some questions about this because of
title 42 obviously put in place in the
early days of coke of 19 where is the
administration in trying to work around
this
well right now as i noted i think the
other day there are discussions about um
any ways we could be helpful and in
welcoming refugees um into the united
states something the present ukrainian
refugees of course we welcome many
refugees as you know something the
president is um willing of course happy
to do the role we've been playing today
kristin has been uh really providing
humanitarian assistance we've provided
300 million in humanitarian assistance
to the people in ukraine and neighboring
countries a lot of that is going to help
provide support to refugees three
million in three weeks which is a
startling number um that are going to
neighboring countries and the bipartisan
funding bill the president just signed a
couple of days ago provides more than
four billion dollars in humanitarian
assistance including 2.65 billion
dollars through the usaid uh
international disaster assistance
program which provides everything from
food health care other urgent support
and 1.4 billion for migration and
refugee assistance to support refugees
fleeing ukraine uh but that is where
because the vast vast majority of
refugees want to stay in neighboring
countries that is where we have been
focusing our energies at this point it
has been clear that he welcomes those
who do want to come here but given this
block
are there discussions about revoking
title 42
the revocation of title 42 wouldn't be
done in response to a war in a european
country it's done by
a decision would be made by the cdc and
then it would be implemented uh when
that is done and it will be done at some
point of course um with the interagency
including department of homeland
security uh but you know there is a
range of discussions
about uh if there are ways for ukrainian
refugees to come
right now they'd have to apply obviously
through existing refugee programs where
they would apply from a third country go
ahead um thanks jen given the covet
surge in china and the lockdowns that
we're seeing there is supply chain
issues and
you know those getting worse perhaps
going to be part of the call tomorrow at
all or is it focused on mostly on russia
uh it will be focused on a range of
issues um certainly russia and ukraine
russia's invasion of ukraine will be a
part of that but uh our economic
relationship with china
a range of uh of issues of mutual uh
concern will certainly be a discussion
so i don't i will we will have more to
read out for you once the once the
meeting uh concludes tomorrow and this
is of course an issue that we are
watching very closely well the ports i
believe still remain open one of the
challenges we've seen uh on the ground
then we are tracking very closely is the
number of um manufacturing facilities or
the number of workers who are not
working sometimes there's a lag in what
that impact can be in terms of the
production of materials and how that
impacts the supply chain so we are
tracking that very closely
but again i expect this to be a wide
ranging conversation tomorrow and we'll
have more to read out once it's
concluded it's a follow-up on the
president being around
some people who've not tested positive
why not just test the pet president
every day at this point the
administration has done a lot in terms
of you know saying
certain actions are being done out of an
abundance of caution so in this case
even if it doesn't quite follow cdc
guidelines or goes above and beyond why
not just do that because he's the
president because we're guided by his
medical doctor
and he uh has kept him at the same
cadence and if that changes then we will
change how often he's tested cadence
once a week or yeah okay
good job questions on a couple different
topics sure try this a different way
does the president have specific things
he wants to accomplish in tomorrow's
conversation with president xi are there
specific deliverables he's hoping to get
out of it well this is again an
opportunity for him to speak directly
leader to leader about a range of issues
of course the invasion of russia russia
and russia's invasion of ukraine will be
a part of that and what role or how how
president xi sees the role of china uh
in that conflict will be a part of that
there's also a range of other topics
that they will discuss but i'm
purposefully leaving some space for the
president to have a direct conversation
with his counterpart and then on the
covet cases that for example with the
second gentleman testing positive this
week um
why
did the vice president appear today i
understand she was asked um but in an
event with other people around when
cdc guidance is currently that people
who have been exposed should stay home
and not interact with others for five
days well she is fully boosted um i
don't actually believe that's accurate
description of cdc guidance of having a
close contact uh we obviously all have
had close contacts here and you're
tested at a regular cadence and she is
abiding by that
thanks jen um just to kind of follow up
on that
uh bet on covet is one of the reasons
why the administration is not going
being extra cautious with the president
and the vice president even though there
is national security issues around us in
part to kind of lead by example for
americans to say
you can get back to living your
normal lives and you shouldn't be
concerned that even if you get exposed
to somebody just briefly you shouldn't
freak out about that you don't need to
test a bunch of times is that basically
the dynamic that you're trying to say
even though
the president 79 years old president of
the united states were to get covet
might be more serious than
uh you know somebody in their 20s well
we don't know that um but we also know
that covet impacts people of all ages
and
a range of but we take what we do here
jen is not not exactly as you said so i
wouldn't agree with your description
there i would say we do take extra
precautions including
individuals who are around the president
being tested that goes over and above of
course he is the president of the united
states um so we do take those additional
steps um and we of course abide by uh
what the recommendations and advice are
of his medical doctor and if that would
be to do increased testing we would
certainly do that but he does not feel
that that is necessary at this point in
time based on these recent
contacts i also wanted to ask about oil
and gas companies and um
there has been some some reports from
the fourth quarter of them increasing
their stock buybacks there was already
you know a time when there was a spike
in gas prices last year i think in the
fourth quarter
um
and you're also just seeing the
companies saying
that they're kind of reluctant to up
production and they kind of in some ways
point to the administration's policies
overall in the sense that even if they
were up production that one takes months
to get to market and two
doesn't fit in with the overall approach
that this administration is taking so
what do you say to
to that kind of viewpoint well i i think
it's hard for them to make the argument
it's anything other than business
decisions on their part
and they have said that themselves
the ceo of occidental petroleum said
quote we have no need and no intent to
invest in production gross 50 this year
ceo of marathon oil said quote our cash
flow driven return of capital framework
uniquely prioritizes our shareholders as
the first call on cash flow generation
not the drill bit ceo of pioneer natural
resources said quote we're not going to
change our growth rate we think it's
important to return cash back to
shareholders that's a business decision
the oil and gas industry right now is
receiving profit windfall profits we've
seen that they publicly report their
profits they publicly report this
information and instead of keeping up
with current demand to many of these
companies and our view are making the
calculated decision of returning money
to investors and shareholders through
buybacks and dividends instead of
expanding production enough in the short
term which is what we need again it's a
business decision but i think there's
clear evidence of them acknowledging and
even shouting that out go ahead so the
china question and with full awareness
of the new south dakota st patrick's day
question oh okay uh question first about
a week ago you said that um for
everything else by and large the white
house saw china is still abiding by
international sanctions but on russia
does that do you still hold a week later
is that generally how the white house
views china i don't have a new
assessment of that we're obviously
watching very closely
saint patrick's day um given the fact
the president very much likes to share
his pride about his heritage but also
the fact that so many more irish than
irish what is that what he said irish
americans consider themselves more i
think that's true i will confirm that go
ahead like that and also the fact that
so many of the ceremonial parts of the
job council of the i'm wondering did he
express particular frustration or
sadness that the oval meeting had to
become yet another zoom meeting today he
was disappointed um he was looking
forward to having the meeting today and
and having meetings over zoom i think as
we've all experienced are not the same
having spent a lot of time with the
president he is an extrovert extrovert
extrovert and loves that engagement with
people and person and he was really
looking forward to the meeting today
there will be more in the future
we certainly understand we are still
facing the pandemic and uh there are
more events that he has been able to
participate in today to celebrate st
patrick's day so uh fortunately many of
them still move forward go ahead thanks
jim um yesterday in his remarks to the
uh congress president zielinski had
called for the creation of this new
global organization that he called u-24
united for peace described as an
alliance that would supply assistance
including weapons within 24 hours i was
wondering if the administration has a
view on that
um idea is it something that you guys
are discussing with ukraine
and does the us view this as zelinski's
kind of alternative for ukraine entering
nato
well i would say just to reiterate it's
up to nato to determine who enters nato
and obviously any country uh we would
support their aspiration to join nato
should they choose and they meet the
requirements we of course did see him
convey that in the speech we don't have
more details we are very closely engaged
with the ukrainians and speak with them
every day uh beyond that i would say in
terms of the delivery of weapons we we
do it as quickly as we humanly possibly
can um through our system and in
coordination with our nato nato partners
and allies but uh we know we support a
range of ideas being put out there we'll
discuss it with the europeans and others
and
and see if there's more to report out
from there i just want to try
one more time go ahead on the president
and covet okay a lot of the questions
are focused on testing which are pretty
clear that the testing cadence is not
changing
um as he looks particularly to a trip
next week that is quite important to
brussels and maybe elsewhere in europe
is there anything else that he's doing
i mean as he's having these uh what the
cdc does not consider a close contact
but are certainly people that he's
around and aware of um is anything about
his behavior changing are there any
other precautions that you guys are
taking that are not testing related
we have we have um continued to take the
same testing protocol steps which are
significant and go farther than cdc
guidance goes uh but beyond that uh the
his testing cadence remains the same and
there haven't been additional changes to
our internal protocols
go ahead hey thanks jen uh the crippling
the kremlin responded uh president biden
labeling putin a war criminal yesterday
but calling his remarks uh unacceptable
and unforgivable unforgivable what is
the white house's reaction to getting
criticism from russia
about the president's remarks it's
pretty rich coming from a country where
whose actions are unforgivable uh in the
eyes of the world global community
given that there's an ongoing legal
process an investigation by the state
department into whether there
was in fact
war crimes committed what is the purpose
of the president and now secretary of
state getting ahead of that
investigation i know you said or the
president you said yesterday that uh the
president was speaking from his heart is
that what this is just just speaking
from their heart well i think secretary
blinken was as well um and
uh as you heard secretary blinken convey
in his remarks what we're seeing whether
it is the
um destruction of a theater where the
words children or kids was written in
russian outside of the theater according
to photos
or whether it is the uh you know
targeting of uh civilians of hospitals
of maternity wards uh if that's not uh
considered a war crime by human beings
what is uh and there is a legal process
that is important uh to continue um that
we have at the state department that is
ongoing that secretary blinken spoke
about and any of that information and
data we gather would go to the
international bodies that would
have prosecuted war criminals in the
past that's where that information would
go it wouldn't be the united states
doing that it's the international bodies
that do that so we will continue to feed
information into that but uh you know i
think it's important to call out what we
see happening on the grounds and i think
that's exactly what the president and
the secretary did go ahead i would go to
those international bodies would the u.s
uh have a response if uh that uh
investigation does conclude that there
were war crimes well typically it's an
international response and it goes
through these international systems for
a reason so we will continue to provide
data and information to that process one
more question on behalf of a colleague
they're growing calls from civil rights
advocates and some lawmakers to pass
temporary protected status for cameroon
some have alleged a double standard in
how the administration prioritizes
predominant predominantly black and
brown countries when it comes to
immigration uh for example took seven
months to grant tps status for
afghanistan but only took about a week
to grant tps uh to ukraine is tps for
cameron something the
administration is considering looking at
the department of homeland security who
oversees that process go ahead thanks
jen um this morning senator mitch
mcconnell was talking about judge
katanji brown jackson on the senate
floor he was specifically talking about
how some of her supporters have framed
her experience as a public defender and
he said quote if any judicial nominee
does have special emphasis empathy for
some parties over others that's not an
asset it's a problem he also said the
president is deliberately working to
make the whole federal judiciary softer
on crime do you have a response to that
he also said he expected her to get
confirmed with some republican votes
what i would say though because there
are others
in the senate who have made faulty
accusations about judge contagio
brown-jackson's record
and specifically
about her record on child sex crime so
let me just take the opportunity to
clear that up not that most people have
confusion about it but in the vast
majority of cases involving child sex
crimes that sentences judge jackson
imposed were consistent with or above
what the government or u.s probation
recommended uh for example uh there are
there are arguments that have been made
out there by senator holly and others
that where he took a snippet of a
transcript out of context when in fact
judge jackson was repeating something a
witness said in order to ask a question
about their testimony so some who are
accusing her of being quote soft on
crime also failed to note that uh that
what was omitted as a sentencing
commission report that's been touted out
there was unanimously supported by a
bipartisan uh sentencing commission she
comes from a
law enforcement family has devoted her
career to standing up for the rule of
law which is why she is endorsed by so
many leading law enforcement
organizations in the country and
attempts to smear or discredit her
history and her work are not borne out
in facts i know monday is a long ways
away given the news cycle all relative
yeah will the president
stop at around 11 to watch uh the
beginning of the hearing of on capitol
hill and will the schedule be adjusted
around that i don't know what his
schedule is yet uh i'm certain that he
will uh possible trip to poland
can you confirm that such a trip is
under consideration
i don't have any more details about his
trip to announce at this point in time
as we have them we will announce them
all to you one more uh there are
negotiations on going between uh
ukraine and russia
does the white house support those
negotiations and
how can you describe your involvement
the u.s involvement in those
talks uh between russia and ukraine well
we've been involved in a couple of ways
one we've been leading the effort to
build support in the global community to
put in place sanctions that are
crippling the russian economy to provide
military support and economic support to
the ukrainians that strengthen their
hand as they participate in these
discussions and negotiations and we also
engage every day with ukrainians to
discuss obviously i would note that
as you know our national security
advisor also talked to his counterpart
yesterday as well but we are continuing
to support the ukrainian's efforts what
our concern is though is uh you know
these diplomatic talks as they're
ongoing we have seen no effort no
movement no evidence that president
putin and the russians are de-escalating
and that is really what we are going to
continue to closely watch
follow up on your point about uh senator
holly obviously he's consistently voted
against the president's nominees don't
think he was a swing vote you guys were
counting on however will his criticism
will the explosiveness of this line of
attack do you worry that it will affect
your ability to win over other
republican votes
is there any concern about this campaign
upping the pressure i'd say senators
collins and murkowski who may be more
amenable to voting well i'm not sure
that someone who refused to tell people
whether or not he would vote for roy
moore is an effective and credible
messenger on this
go ahead thanks jen um i'm going to try
again on president biden president she's
called tomorrow if you won't detail the
consequences of what happens if china
does start supporting more sport russia
might you indicate whether there are any
carrots that the administration is
prepared to offer perhaps tara
productions
well this is a conversation about where
president xi stands it's up to the
chinese to decide where they want to
stand where they want to be as the
history books are written so i think
it's more uh through that frame than it
is about carrots and then just one more
um two more actually yeah as the
administration continues to
condemn and take action against uh
russia's invasion on ukraine are there
any plans to revisit
review provoke the trump
administration's recognition of israel's
annexations on the golan heights and
morocco's annexation of western sahara i
don't have any updates on that front i'd
point to the state department what can
you do can you describe just the
administration's position on the
difference between russia's invasion on
ukraine and israel's annexation i point
you to the state department go ahead
logistical question
cambodia the chair of asean has
announced last week that the u.s asean
summit that the president's supposed to
host on the 28th i believe is postponed
uh we haven't been able to get a
confirmation from either uh you guys or
state can you clarify that i don't have
any updates on the schedule i know we
were working through the schedules of a
number of leaders uh so that's always a
challenge and a factor but i don't have
any updates on the table i don't have
any updates on it go ahead thank you jen
uh two on on covid um there are some
americans who have received a second
booster i.e for a fourth total shot is
that something that the president has
done or will do
he has not done that if the cdc
recommends it he would get another
booster they have not and then secondly
uh the white house chief of staff ron
clayne in a tweet today uh celebrating
the idea that
you know who he is uh said and that he
tweets uh you said
he said celebrated the idea that there's
a low number of americans in icus today
uh because of covet but he also wrote
there's a great risk of a new wave and
there are certainly we're seeing cases
surge right now in china and in europe
and one of the truisms of this pandemic
if it's in europe it ends up here a few
weeks later what precautions and
preparations is the administration
taking
federally and encouraging states to take
ahead of a possible new covenant with so
what what we have seen and i think
you're talking about the ba2 variant and
we are closely watching and monitoring
the situation both in europe and in
china uh b2 is more transmissible
version of omicron
we do know uh the tools the united
states has including the mrna vaccines
therapeutics and tests all are effective
tools against this variant and china has
not used mrna vaccines which is an
important component of seeing response
or or how it's impacting people there
but ba 2 has been circulating here a
little different from omicron when we
were going through that surge in in
november has been circulating here for
some time uh we currently it may be
higher than this but as of earlier this
week there were about 35 000 cases in
this country and we expect some
fluctuation especially at this
relatively low level but this is an
example of where the president's
preparedness plan that we rolled out
just a couple of weeks ago
which lays out what the tools are that
we need to move forward safely is
important and what we've been conveying
to governors to go to your question or
leaders around the country and certainly
members of congress is that
just because cobit isn't disrupting some
of our lives in certain communities as
much as it was a few weeks ago it
doesn't mean it's gone it's not gone um
and i think this variant is an example
of that
we do know what we need to manage it but
we are also at great risk of running out
of money to do exactly that and so that
is a key part of what we're
communicating to governors to members of
congress and others about where we are
with funding and the need to end some of
these programs soon if we don't get the
funding we need it's a very short quick
follow-up is there concern though that
this variant which is seen as very
transmissible is coming at a moment when
a lot of americans are seeing waning
protection from their boosters just
because the timing of the shots as well
as the fact that mass guidelines other
regulations have been lifted across the
country it's a good question i would
point to our medical experts to answer
that i mean it is more transmissible but
we know it can be treated so i think
what it is is a reminder of is that
while it has uh decreased uh in many uh
parts of the country uh it is not gone
and it means we still need to uh
continue to take steps we can to fight
the virus go ahead
um japan holds the largest number of u.s
military about 50 000 troops about half
a million americans at any given time in
japan and many japanese remember
at that time vice president biden came
all the way to japan about 10 years ago
and there's a terrible disaster
but there's been no interview with any
japanese media um you know we can
arrange that just to assure that
that that the treaty is in force and
especially the senkaku the southern
islands they're very worried about um
he does have a great deal of affection
for japan and uh has spoken of course
with their uh the current leader a
couple of times um i'm happy to take
your interview request under under
advisement go
ahead i wanted to ask you about the
refugee situation in ukraine does the
white house see the refugee situation
that was created in afghanistan last
year
as different than the one created by
russia's invasion of ukraine and the
reason i say that is
is your policy response different i hear
you say that
your understanding is that neighboring
countries that's where people are going
from ukraine right now
and not necessarily coming here but at
some point is that going to not be an
option anymore
uh well it's different in part for the
reason you mentioned that um in ukraine
there are well there have been three
million refugees or about that number
over the last couple of weeks
they have been
the vast vast majority of them have
moved into countries neighboring
countries who have set up really
remarkable systems for
welcoming these refugees at a really
challenging and difficult time i know
there's been a lot of reporting from a
lot of your networks
in poland and other places where they
have had systems in place to welcome
refugees that has been the preference of
these refugees that's why we have been
providing our humanitarian assistance
to these countries and to ukraine
directly in order to help
augment the support in in the best way
possible every refugee circumstance is
different
and has different needs and requirements
and we try to adapt our own response
from usaid or from our refugee and
migration programming and and funding to
meet what the needs are in that conflict
i also wanted to ask on a completely
different topic the president in the
state of the union said that he would
sign a an executive order on identity
theft um and
i think he called it pandemic aid fraud
or something similar
do you have an update on where that is i
know it hasn't been published yet
um well let's see um
what we know at this point in time is
that um he talked about addressing
unemployment fraud right through the
pandemic and so what we're doing now is
ensuring um
that we're taking steps toward that last
week the department of justice announced
a new chief pandemic prosecutor and
we're working to escalate efforts to
crack down on bad actors and support and
augment that
but in terms of the executive order i
don't have an update on the timeline on
it let's go in the back um jen two
questions one foreign policy one
domestic okay i like this setup
sure
so are you what do you make of the fact
that there now appear to be uh chechen
and maybe syrian regular forces
uh fighting on behalf of russia in
ukraine
i don't have any confirmation of that
from here
um
and then on on the domestic front um
kathy hokul the governor of new york
uh
proposed today making changes to the
state's uh progressive bail reform law
and it looks like mayor adams
who i think we can describe as a an ally
of the president support those changes
so does this administration stand by its
what i would describe as a wholesale
endorsement of bail reform
i would have to check on the specifics
of the new york changes i haven't looked
into those i'm happy to do that and talk
to our council's office about that we'll
get back to you go ahead yeah so the the
chinese have been very public about how
they're going to continue their normal
economic activity with russia is the
president going to press president xi on
that and is he going to ask them to sort
of back off their activity like the rest
of the world well i think that the
conversation tomorrow will be a
continuation of the conversation our
national security
advisor had with his counterpart
earlier this week and certainly china's
alignment with russia in a range of ways
is and the potential implications and
consequences of that are a central part
of that conversation and then uh
domestically on another subject the
congressional progressive caucus
recommendations for executive action uh
are out and they're asking for a
decision to declare a climate emergency
and ban all u.s exports of oil um is
that something the president is thinking
about doing there are a range of really
good ideas out there um presidents
looking at all of them
but i don't have anything to predict for
you at this point in time
to start for the room when is the
president going to nominate a new fed
nominee
well i would say that
one of the most eminently qualified
people ever to be nominated um only
withdrew her nomination i think 48 hours
ago 72 hours ago it's all running
together he very much intends to
nominate another eminently qualified
person but i don't have an update on the
timeline of that let the financial wires
games begin go ahead again um
if the u.s plans to still engage with
russia on the iran nuclear deal and
perhaps some of these other climate
initiatives
what does president biden expect russia
to bring to the table i know what the
goal is that we don't want iran to have
a nuclear weapon but
how does the president think
that putin will
be helpful after the president
rightfully turns him into a pariah on
the global stage as it relates to the
iran nuclear deal um i think that our
view on this is that it's not obviously
in our interests and it's it's not in
russia's interest either for iran to
acquire a nuclear weapon and so while
these negotiations i mean the people are
back in their capitals at this point in
time as you know but they're for all
intensive purposes ongoing there have
been roles in implementation that russia
has had in the past but
i think what we recognize is that it's
not in their interest either and
we will consider continue pursuing the
diplomatic path forward one more
the new york times has authenticated
emails that appear to have come from a
laptop abandoned by hunter biden in
delaware
the president previously said the new
york post story about this was a bunch
of garbage and that it was a russian
plant does he stand by that assessment i
appointed the department of justice and
also to hunter biden's representatives
he doesn't work in the government go
ahead
um so
through the recent peace talks going on
between ukraine and russia as we've
already mentioned
um it seems that uh a couple of the
things that are being floated uh one
some sort of
withdrawal by russia but they still hold
on to these pieces of ukraine they
already have in east and crimea so my
first question is would the u.s
ever
back that kind of deal if it was
something the ukrainians agreed or felt
they had to agree with we're here to
support the ukrainians but we're not
going to negotiate about a negotiation
that
has not uh has not resulted in even the
implementation of humanitarian corridors
at this point uh fair enough so and but
the the other things we flooded by
zavinsky himself is uh that he basically
the other day ukrainians get used to
we're not going to be in nato they're
never going to want us but then he said
what we would like is some kind of other
security guarantees is that something
that you're talking about and what on
earth would that look like
it's a decision for president zilensky
and ukrainians to make if they're going
to pursue membership in nato decision
for nato to make if they're going to be
members including in in terms of other
security guarantees we're in touch
regularly with them but i don't have
more information of what that would look
like is the president talking about some
kind of long-term new mechanism where
the u.s somehow or western countries or
europe somehow
protect i think that's a little
premature at this point in time uh go
ahead
on back to the weapons package yeah
until now the administration has been
really very tight-lipped about what was
being sent to ukraine yeah yesterday
that all changed got a whole laundry
risk can you is that a change in
strategy in messaging is that a message
for you before about the russian troop
morale for example or maybe a message to
domestic critics or president biden
what's changed there well we made a
decision that we wanted to be very clear
about uh what types of security
assistance we're providing and how it is
helping ukrainians fight the russian
russia's war against them and so yes you
could say that was a change a decision
to make that information available and
we don't typically to your point outline
all of those specifics publicly um so
but we did determine made a
determination to do that because we felt
it was important for all of you in the
american public to fully understand the
range of military and security
assistance we're providing how it's
working and how it's helping them in
this war
in that sort of decision
it was not
but
it was more a decision about
recognizing that everybody doesn't
always understand what many people in
this room do when we say security
assistance what that is and how it helps
uh the ukrainians um fight this war and
there is an understandable uh outpour of
support of compassion for the plight of
the ukrainian people and we want to
provide as much detail as we can about
how we're trying to help them in this
war and if i may um you're asked about
hunter biden's laptop you also in
october 2020 dismissed it as russian
disinformation do you stand by that
assessment again uh i appointed the
department of justice and hunter biden's
representatives i'm a spokesperson for
the united states he doesn't work for
the united states go ahead go ahead and
okay we'll do the last one here okay
thank you then uh i have two kitchens
one north korea and china
north korea fired a new missiles
day before yesterday
what is the uh
president biden's reaction on this and
and how do you analyze the type of
missiles
i'll follow up the second question
well we condemn uh north korea's missile
launches that north korea's tests risk
raising tensions and are destabilizing
to the indo-pacific our commitment to
the defense of the republic of korea and
japan remains iron-clad as we have said
and north korean officials including kim
jong-un have publicly noted we continue
to seek diplomacy and are prepared to
meet without preconditions but north
korea continues to not respond
when the president biden talked with the
susan king president of china
tomorrow
who do he are going to discuss with the
president susan king regarding north
koreans and beside
provocations i expect there'll be a
range of topics discussed including
security in the region but uh we'll have
more to read out when that conversation
continues is done thanks everyone see
you tomorrow
you